look detachment is a great tool as a
leader to have because it allows you to
take a step back and see what's going on
right
clearly it's a powerful tool but you
combine that aspect of detachment to
this other aspect of detachment when
when we've talked about people that get
caught in a bad mental headspace and I
don't know if I want to use the word
depression because I'm not a
psychologist and I've never really had
this depression so I can't really speak
about it from that angle but to say that
people get caught in a rut that happens
mm-hmm and I've talked about that ideal
like let's say okay when you win if you
lose someone right someone that you know
dies and you get put into that rut and
the way I've described it before is like
there's a storm cloud all around your
head and no matter which direction you
look you see storm cloud and anyone
that's on the outside and this is what
I've said anyone that's on the outside
looking and go oh man you're just
surrounded by the storm if you if you
step over here you're gonna get away
from that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel but from their perspective
they don't see it at all if you can
detach if you can take a step back from
your own head you can actually see the
end of the storm clouds and you can see
that you can get your way out of this
rut that you're in mm-hmm now people ask
me about how to detach and I talked
about it leadership strategy and tactics
but I'm gonna take a little bit further
think about this so here's a couple
things and actually the reason that I I
start I used to kind of look at it like
hey it's real simple right hey take a
step back just take a step back take a
breath right you know look around in
fact relax look around and make a call
was what I wrote about extreme ownership
when when it comes to detached like
relax look around make a call that's
detachment the the first time I really
broke it down to try and give people
some more specific instructions
was on the warrior kid podcast cuz you
know a little kid would say when I get
mad I start to lose my temper when I'm
wrestling or I start to lose my temper
when I'm in class and little Billie's
keeps poking me in the back of the head
how do I not lose my temper well what
they need to do is detach so I said
listen take a step back so I thought
about what I kind of do take a step back
and one of the things I said was lift
your chin up mmm lift your chin up and
now now when you start to think I said
talking about why do I even do that what
what benefit does that have well if you
think about when you take a step back
and you actually lift up your chin think
about what it does to your vision all of
a sudden your vision is elevated it's an
elevated one inch but it's elevated and
you now have a physical new perspective
you have a physically new perspective of
what's going on by taking a step back
lifting your chin up the other thing it
makes you do is if you put your head
back it like makes you open up your
chest and open up your lungs and it
makes you take a breath which I used to
attribute this to when you're on the
radio look one of the reasons that I was
like thought about detaching and
something that I caught realized was a
good tools you never want to sound
panicked on the radio and the SEAL Teams
so before you key up that microphone to
say something you go
whether you say all right guys we need
to move towards that North Building
instead of no you don't do that so when
you when you lift your chin up you you
know you kind of take a breath it forces
you to kind of take a breath and the
other this is the coolest thing that I
kind of connected this at Chaco Life and
the reason I connected it because I was
up like right now we're sitting down and
we're kind of we're kind of stuck in
this position so I'd talk alive I had
that God like a lavalier microphone on
Saul's up and moving around and getting
crazy so as I was going through this I
was acting out the the process of
detaching so I take a step back I lift
up my chin and I made this connection I
was like think about the posture that
you have when you're getting ready to
get into a fight it's literally the
opposite you lift up your hands you duck
you tuck your chin down you roll your
shoulders forward to protect yourself
and you are getting in this defensive
posture which is not an open posture for
seeing what's going on right it's a
focused posture when you take a step
back you lift up your chin you're
actually making yourself physically
vulnerable and what you're also doing is
you're so you're opening yourself up to
threats but you're opening up your mind
to see a different perspective so that
is incredibly important it's an
incredibly important first step in
training yourself how to detach from all
this chaos that's going on from the
mayhem of a leadership situation to
detaching from your own ecosystem that
you're wrapped up in that you think is
important that no one cares about no one
cares about outside that stupid Club
you're in no one cares no one cares
outside the the the the 38 people that
are involved in your glee club they've
got you paranoid
I'm freaking out no one cares so if you
can take a step back and you can see
that and finally if you can take a step
back from your own brain and you can
kind of assess that cloud that you're
caught in you'll see that that cloud is
not infinite and you'll see that there's
a way out
mm-hmm which is important very important